you may hold my fate in your hands like
a small bird
but i still think you're an ass
you want to get a beer it's like 10 30
in the morning yeah
you seem like you could use a beer let's
get a beer
favorite place upstairs there's this
mural of wildflowers and i like to sit
on a bench in front of it
really it could be anywhere in the world
paris hawaii
the grand canyon nope just the bench in
front of the mural what about like an
actual meadow where wildflowers are ew
and i'm scared of bees
mural hey i never get to tell you the
rest of my ideas you want to go
somewhere and talk about them yeah yeah
i'd love to um let me
get some actual food and then um
do you know that wildflower mural up on
the second floor
mm-hmm yeah you want to meet there
yeah okay sounds good i don't know if
the online thing is for me
i prefer to meet people in person how
long have you been sleeping
with ben that's disgusting and wrong i
don't even get
why would i i've never had sex with
anyone anywhere it's not a your
you have the nerve the audacity
ben is my boss technically and he is
terrible
face wise and how how
do i know frankly that you're not
sleeping with him maybe you are maybe
you're trying to throw me off hmm
check and mate
this is an outrage who do i call hey
hey hey hey hey ron hey listen you're
just who i was looking for
are you did you forget the um
did you can can i get that thing can we
just uh
did you bring it this isn't convincing
i know i've been acting really weird
lately and um
i really like you what i'm about to say
is going to contradict the idea that i
really like you but that's that's that's
that's
that's
that's
that's
that's that's
that's
that's
that's
that's that's that's that's that's that one
just open the box please stop breaking
out the box okay
leslie you're being really nice and what
i'm about to say is gonna make you hate
me okay then i'll just open the box for
you
wow you knew
i figured it out a while ago i'm sorry i
should have told you i knew but i just i
wanted this to last as long as possible
we have to break up why
why do we have to break up well leslie
everything you've accomplished
you have earned and you have worked for
i don't want anyone to think that you
got where you are today
by sleeping with your boss but i really
like sleeping with my boss
yeah yeah you know the meeting that ben
and i had
it's on the record you should take a
look at the last page of the transcript
mr wyatt chris for god's sake would you
mind not jumping for a little while
mr trigger sorry ben but this is how i
fight depression
okay fine i'll stop thank you okay
so you are prepared to
resign effective immediately and take
full responsibility for all the events
that transpired a little sebastian's
memorial
mr wyatt that is correct that is correct
mr trager
okay fine this makes me sadder than i
previously
thought humanly possible but i accept
your resignation
can i ask you one more question was all
of this
all the the sneaking around the scandal
losing your job was was it worth it
yes it was
because i love leslie i want to be with
her and i don't want to hide the way
i feel about her anymore so yeah it was
worth it because i'm in love with leslie
no
mr traeger that was beautiful i'm
literally crying and jumping
crying noise crying noise nose blow
mr wyatt it's gonna be okay mr traeger
let it out i guess end transcript
hi honey how was your day oh i've had
better
how about you i can't believe you did
that for me
well i was pretty sure it was gonna
happen one way or the other
i hope it doesn't affect your campaign
don't worry about that right now
there was a piece of testimony that came
out during the trial that i think you'd
be interested in
ethel ethel could you
please read page 132 of the official
testimony
ethel beavers the official record has
now annoyingly been reopened
so that leslie knope can make a
statement
leslie knope let the record state that i
leslie knope love ben wyatt i love him
with all of my heart
did you get that ethel beavers yes
i got it thank you ethel
can i get a ride home it's freezing
well my boyfriend might not be moving
back for a while so i have to back out
just wanted to look at it one more time
you know i can't give you your deposit
back
i know and there's a 300 all right
martha
i get it
actually is there a way i could put down
like a
hey hey you know you were coming back
here
oh what are you doing
oh my god what are you doing i'm
thinking about my future
i am deeply ridiculously
in love with you and above everything
else i just i
i want to be with you forever
so leslie knope wait
wait okay just i need to remember this
sure give me a second
leslie no no no hold on just i need
another second please
i need to remember every
little thing about how perfect my life
is
right now at this exact moment okay
are you good yeah okay i'm good
leslie knope william yes
marry me oh yeah okay
you want to say some stuff about leslie
in my time working for the state
government my job sent me to
46 cities in 11 years
i lived in villages with eight people
rural farming communities college towns
i was sent to every corner
of indiana and then i came here
and i realized that this whole time
i was just wandering around
everywhere just looking for you
leslie do you want to say some stuff
about ben now okay well
the first draft of my vows which i wrote
the day after we got engaged
clocked in at around 70 pages
but i i don't have them with me today
well maybe there's a copy of them in my
office
[Music]
that's fine i think we can just keep
going okay
here's what i'll say though the things
that you have done for me
to help me support me
surprise me to make me happy
go above and beyond what any person
deserves
you're all i need i love you and i like
you
i love you and i like you and now with
the power vested in me by the state of
indiana
i now pronounce you husband and wife
you may now kiss them
i've gathered you all here today because
i have an announcement
a very big announcement about my future
i will be heading to lunch today with my
husband
at jj's diner we will eat waffles and
then we will go home and make out on our
couch that is my future
for now
it's been an honor to serve this town
and i will cherish the memories forever
thank you there you have it a shockingly
unshocking press conference in which a
recently unemployed woman
said nothing of importance i'm perd
happily and i just realized i'm not
holding my microphone
jan barkley telling me i had a future
was the best
present i could have gotten thank you
you're welcome but i did get you one
other president to
take your mind off all this oh you are
the sweetest man in the world where is
it
well it's not here we have to go
get it
in times of stress or moments of
transition
sometimes it can feel like the whole
world is closing in on you
when that happens you should close your
eyes take
a deep breath listen to the people who
love you when they give you advice
and remember what really matters and if
you have the ability to go to paris by
all means
go to paris i found one oh great
right here
[Music]
you